You're a few days out from a 2024 parliamentary election in Korea.
There are 40 parties participating in this election.
I've compiled a list of their election manifestos
and translated them to English.
Today we'll be discussing the Liberal parties
participating in the parliamentary election.
First and largest Liberal party is the Democratic Party of Korea
with their satellite party Together
Democratic Alliance.
Their election pledges include the introduction of a 4.5 day work week,
realizing social structure
that allows for the compatibility of marriage,
birth and childcare, expanding the number of medical students,
establishing an occupational
safety and health system for all working people
so that they do not die at work.
Preventing crisis
and creating an atmosphere of peace on the Korean Peninsula.
The introduction of a universal basic income pilot plan,
realizing of confident diplomacy with Japan based on historical fact,
complete reform of the prosecutor's office
and the neutrality and democratic control of the police.
And lastly,
creating a civil service culture that meets the public's expectations.
The next Liberal party participating in the election
is the new Future Party.
They want a complete decentralization of the presidential system
and the introduction of a presidential runoff system when voting.
They want to remove privileges of lawmakers,
preventing members of parliament from legal prosecution.
They want a lifetime ban on judges and prosecutors
from serving in the National Assembly.
They want to enact the basic acts for the working people
to protect those currently exempt from the Labor Standard Act.
They want a 35 hour work week without a cut to pay
and expand annual leave from 15 days to 25 days.
They want to completely nationalize local fire departments.
They want to establish an office of immigration
under the Public Administration
and security and grand amnesty for migrant children.
They want to abolish the military conscription system
and move towards a completely volunteer military service program.
And they also want to relocate the national capital to Sejong City.
The next Liberal party participating is Rebuilding Korea Party.
They want a complete decentralization of powerful
prosecutorial authorities
through the complete separation of investigation and prosecution.
They want a direct election of prosecutors and indictment jury systems.
Currently South Korea's on its 6th constitution
and the Rebuilding Korea Party
wants to create a seventh Republic of Korea
by adopting a new constitution.
They want to increase the portion of renewable energies to 30% by 2030
and 80% by 2050. They want to reduce the burden of employment, housing,
childcare and support for young women and young people
by establishing a child rearing friendly society.
They want to inspire individuals will for potential growth,
enhancing vitality of society as a whole
through educational innovation.
They want to strengthen local economic competitiveness
through national financial decentralization.
They want to implement foreign security policies
that prevent war on the Korean Peninsula
and lead to peace and prosperity in East Asia.
And lastly,
they seek to transform interkorean relations to peaceful coexistence
based on Cooperation and solidarity.
Last Liberal party is the New Progressive Union.
They have one candidate in Daegu.
Their national candidates are participating on the Democratic Party
proportional representation list.
They want 60% share of renewable energies by 2035.
They want vouchers for electric vehicles and solar panels.
They wanna see a basic income of half a million Korean
one per month for two years to young people aged 20.
They want a basic income of 300,000,
one for farmers. They wanna see free tickets for public transportation.
They want a four day 32 hour work week with no reduction in pay.
They want to enact an anti discrimination law that covers gender,
sexual orientation, disability,
race and employment status.
They want to abolish the death penalty.
And lastly, they want to establish a National Students Human Rights Act
and guarantee the participation of children and adolescents in school
steering committees.
Join us next time as we discuss the conservative camp.